new information may help investigators
solve a high-profile missing person case
for more than two decades ago Jodi
huisentruit was a television anchor at
CBS affiliate KIMT in Mason City Iowa
she was a beloved rising star until she
disappeared on her way to work in 1995
police discovered signs of a struggle
outside her apartment building but her
body was never found Jim Axelrod spoke
to police about new potential leads in
the investigation for 48 hours you are
watching News Channel 3 daybreak the
time is 6 o'clock 64 degrees some light
showers falling in North Iowa this was
the last viewers saw of Jodi huisentruit
before the popular Mason City Iowa
anchor vanished on June 27 1995 we need
your help one of our news anchors is
missing
coworkers knew something was very wrong
when Jodi failed to show up for her 6:00
a.m. newscast at KIMT TV when police
arrived at Jodi's apartment complex they
discovered evidence of an abduction
there were in fact a pair of shoes some
keys a hairdryer and some other items
that were found in the parking lot in
the vicinity of her car good Thursday
morning welcome to daybreak June Jodi's
bubbly personality had won over her
viewers could it have also made her the
target of a stalker Jodi's sister Joanne
Athey says Jodi reported an incident
months earlier she got shook up one day
when she was out hiking or jogging on a
trail a black truck had followed her but
the investigation also included people
Jodi knew and one friend of hers john
vansice put himself on police radar by
declaring he'd been the last person to
see Jodi alive she was like a daughter
to me she was just like my own child I
turned her like my own child and back in
1995 48 hours was on the ground in Mason
City
within days of Jodi's disappearance and
we spent time with vansice nice way
she's alive somewhere
I just hope she's not hurt hope she's
okay
I hope you come back soon vansice denies
involvement in Jodi's disappearance
police have not called him a suspect and
confirm he passed the polygraph
but in 2017 police obtained a search
warrant for GPS information on two of
his vehicles John Jim Axelrod $40
whatever information Mason City police
may have on anyone chief jeff brinkley
isn't sharing why won't you talk about
any specifics in this case I don't want
to let the cat out of the bag but is
there a cat in the bag do you have some
plea
no no I don't think we do yet but I
think that we're very close such a
mystery and Jim Axelrod joins us now you
raised this theory in the piece but do
police think that Jodi may have had a
stalker and if so is there a suspect in
mind well there is this other suspect we
get into tomorrow night so in the late
90s in Minneapolis st. Paul there was a
guy named Tony Jackson it was convicted
when a string of rapes but in June of
1995 when Jodi disappeared
Tony Jackson wasn't living in
Minneapolis he was living in Mason City
and he was living two blocks from the TV
station they seemed to have some
questions to for mr. Vance ice what
exactly was his relationship with her
well john vansice was sort of inner
circle
social pal 22 years older he was a seed
salesman there's a lot of questions we
spent a lot of time with him 23 years
ago when Jodi was abducted we'll see
that for the first time tomorrow night I
will say this when you asked the chief
he says we're close I think we have a
different definition of what closes I
said days weeks months he said not not
that fast yeah so no I like when you
said cat out of the bag and then it said
is there a cat in the bag he seemed to
do a little backpedal on that I remember
in that case very fascinating sad very
sad story about that
we'll be watching all right thank you
and you can watch the 48 hours report
find Jodi tomorrow at 10:00 9:00 central
right here on CBS